there are numerous pieces of literature
that tell the story of one's journey in
the afterlife for many Dante's Inferno
may be the first of these classical
pieces that comes to mind even if it's
not something you've read the name may
still be familiar but this is just one
piece of a three-part work written by
Dante allegieri known as divinia Comedia
The Divine Comedy a narrative poem that
follows the journey one must take after
death as thought of by many during the
Middle Ages so join me today as we
follow Dante in his journey through hell
purgatory and Paradise
before we delve into Dante's wild
Journey this video is brought to you by
manscape.com the global men's Lifestyle
brand that has made the annoyances and
challenges of personal grooming and
hygiene a thing of the past with the
advances made in male grooming manscapes
means you can keep everything nice and
tidy down below without any nightmare
shaving stories however that doesn't
cover the wide range of products that
manscaped has available the Platinum
package 4.0 grooming kit leaves no
Stones unturned the two-in-one manscapes
body wash and shampoo will not only
leave you smelling as fresh as possible
but it's also vegan friendly made with
all natural ingredients as well as being
cruelty and dye free there is an
aluminum-free deodorant stick for your
underarms and the crop preserver board
deodorant will leave you smelling fresh
from head to toe also included are the
manscape Staples the lawnmower 4.0
electric trimmer and the weed whacker
nose and ear trimmer both are waterproof
cordless and made with skin safe
technology to reduce Nicks and cuts when
you opt into the peak hygiene plan you
can have all of these products as well
as replenishments sent straight to your
door manscapes are also giving you two
freebies anti-chafe manscape boxer
briefs and the shed luxury travel bag if
that sounds good go to manscape.com and
use my promo code MFE to get 20 off your
order free international shipping plus
the two free gifts that's 20 percent off
free international shipping and two free
gifts by simply using the code MFE at
checkout
the story is set in the year 1300 Dante
wakes up on the evening of Good Friday
in a dark wood with no recollection of
how he got there in the distance he can
see a Foothill a mountain where the sun
shines bright
he decides it must be safer than the
word and so he starts his ascent
but as he climbs he encounters a leopard
and then a lion and then a she-warf
overwhelmed by these animals he has no
choice but to turn back to the forest
here he comes across a spirit known as
Virgil a once famous poet or bard
he tells Dante that he can guide him to
Paradise
but first they must Journey Through Hell
Dante himself also a Storyteller
immediately feels this connection to
Virgil and so he trusts him as a guide
together they pass through the gates of
hell and begin their Journey
as one would imagine this is not a
pleasant place
a place where all hope is abandoned a
city of Eternal woe and pain
the sky was pitch black but not a single
star could be seen
the air was thick with the moans of
grief and sorrow
Dante recount seeing a flag whirling
through the air being followed by a
train of naked spirits
these Unfortunate Souls were cursed to
chase this unattainable flag while being
stung by wasps and hornets
the tears they wept and the blood from
their wounds dripped onto their feet and
the ground was covered in maggots and
worms
the only way to escape this torment is
to Journey deeper into hell and the only
way to do that is to cross the river
acharon
when they reached the riverbank there
are countless Souls waiting for Caron
the ferryman of the Dead
we can immediately see the influence of
Greek mythology on Dante here the river
acheron running through the underworld
and Caron being the ferryman of the Dead
are taken straight out of Greek myth
Caron eventually agrees to take them
across the river in his boat
when they arrive on the other side The
Virgil explains sedante that this is the
first circle of hell known as limbo the
souls who reside here were not
necessarily bad people in terms of sins
committed but they did not possess the
necessary Faith many of them rejected
Christianity the unbaptized and virtuous
pagans is how they described they may
not have been sinful but they were still
sentenced to an eternity of damnation
and denied entry into Paradise
in the distance there is a large Citadel
which houses many of the Great
philosophers Plato's Socrates Aristotle
and many more
before becoming Dante's guide this was
also the home of Virgil and Dante does
also come across other great poets such
as Homer Ovid and Horus
there are also many great Greek and
Roman musicians Statesmen generals and
Physicians
eventually they depart and make their
way onwards to the second circle of hell
last
the first Circle was undoubtedly a
punishment but those who resided there
still had some Freedom the second Circle
onwards is where the real punishment
began there to greet Souls as they
entered the second Circle was Minos a
giant Serpentine figure in Greek myth
Minos was the son of Zeus and the first
king of Crete after his death he would
become one of the three judges of Hades
in Dante's interpretation he certainly
has a much more monstrous form Minos
would examine the crimes of those bought
before him and give them a sentence that
he felt was fitting
he would wrap his tail around himself a
certain amount of times and that number
would determine which Circle they were
sentenced to the second circle of hell
was intended for those who had succumbed
to lust and many of these were kings
queens and rulers such as Cleopatra
Helen of Troy Paris and achilles
Dante views lust as a mutual Indulgence
and therefore sees it as the least
heinous of sins the punishment is also
the most lenient inside of Hell itself
with help from Virgil Dante is allowed
past Minos and they enter the third
circle of hell gluttony
here there is an icy rain that never
stops
as punishment for their insatiable
appetites the gluttonous are left to
wallow and squirm around in the vile and
putrid mud like worms gelatinous masses
unable to stand or even crawl
guarding them is the three-headed Hound
Cerberus who patrols up and down this
filthy Maya flaying and mauling the
gluttonous with his claws tearing their
Spirits as they helplessly scream
luckily Virgil manages to calm Cerberus
and they are able to pass safely through
they come across a few spirits who have
suffered in this circle for some time
these Unfortunate Souls no longer have
bodies and resemble not much more than
foul smelling liquid
Dante then meets a spirit that he
doesn't recognize called chiako chiako
however recognizes Dante from back home
in Florence he also gives him the first
of many political prophecies or
predictions he inquires about the state
of civil conflict within Florence and
then tells Dante that the party he
aligns with will be expelled with aid
from Rome
in the fourth circle of hell Dante
encounters a figure known as Pluto a
deity of wealth
we soon discover that this is the circle
of greed where those who cared too much
from Material Goods would be punished
they are divided into two separate
groups the first consisted of those who
would hoard their possessions and money
the second consisted of those who spent
their money freely neglected the value
of their possessions and squandered
everything they had
these two groups were cursed to push
enormous weights up a hill only to meet
each other in the Middle where they
would argue why do you hoard one group
would ask why do you waste the other
would respond when they clashed in the
middle they would knock each other and
the weights down to the bottom only to
repeat the process again and again
the hoarders and wasters are housed
together as a punishment forever arguing
and screaming never listening or trying
to understand the other's perspective
a pretty accurate description of today's
society sadly
as they descend deeper they reach the
river sticks and the fifth circle of
hell
Wrath
the river is more of a swampy mire where
the wrathful fight and battle
the boatmen known as flying legus
arrives and after a short disagreement
with Virgil he agrees to Ferry them to
the other side
as they journey across the marsh a soul
jumps up and grabs the boat
Filippo argenti a bitter political rival
of Dante back in Florence the two
exchanged some rather harsh words and
Dante wishes for felipo to suffer more
punishment ironically Dante's Behavior
here is not too different from the souls
that reside in this circle
in the far distance Dante notices fiery
towers and burning Wars Virgil explains
that they are approaching the city of
dis in the lower portion of hell where
the Heretics are housed
when they arrive they are denied entry
by the Fallen Angels who guard the gates
they Grant virtual passage with only one
condition that he may never return to
his own Circle
it's at this point Dante begins to worry
that he may never leave hell himself
Virgil agrees to enter alone and open
the gates from the inside for Dante but
in this task he is unsuccessful
he returns to Dante with the angels
slamming the gate shut behind him but he
vows to Dante that he will not abandon
him despite both poets being terrified
Virgil is adamant that their Journey
shall continue
for the first time Dante starts to doubt
his guide having seen Virgil fail it's
also apparent that he has no real plan
and things can only get worse
he asks Virgil if he's ever been this
deep into hell before and Virgil replies
that he has ventured this deep into hell
once before when the Sorceress aricto
sent him to retrieve a soul for one of
her necrotic rituals
all of a sudden out of nowhere appeared
the furies
three female figures stained in blood
with serpents entwined around their
bodies
electo meguera and to Symphony
they were far from pleased to see Dante
and decided to summon Medusa to turn him
into stone Virgil warns Dante of
Medusa's gaze and covers his eyes to
ensure he isn't turned into stone and
Trapped In Hell forever
from the River Styx emerges a figure
that Virgil recognizes and he tells
Dante to Bow and remain quiet
as the Angelic figure approaches it
becomes clear that it was sent from
heaven the furies immediately flee in
Terror and the angels who denied entry
are reprimanded the angel then does what
Virgil could not and opens the gates
allowing the two poets to enter
the city of dies or the city of Dieter
contains circles six through nine with
circle 6 being located just within its
walls and the rest closer to the center
in the circle of heresy Dante and Virgil
come across a group of Heretics who have
been locked inside burning tombs as
punishment these were known as the
epicureans a sex of people who believed
when the body died so did the soul and
so they valued pleasure Above All Else
as it allowed them to enter a state of
Tranquility so they lived their lives
believing pleasure allowed them to
escape all sorts of pain and discomfort
which makes their punishment in hell all
the more ironic
Dante comes across two of the tortured
Souls one of which is from Florence but
once again is on the opposite side of
Dante politically
before leaving this region The Poets
experience the most vile smell
imaginable permeating from the lower
regions a smell was so bad they had to
stop and rest
Virgil takes this time to explain what
they will encounter next the next three
circles contain smaller circles inside
themselves
the circle of violence for example is
divided into three sections in the first
you have Those who commit an acts of
violence against others and their
property in the second you have those
who committed acts of violence against
themselves such as suicide and lastly
you have those who committed acts of
violence against God or nature
as their time shortens they must descend
into Circle seven the circle of violence
before entering the circle they must
pass a narrow passage of broken rocks
here they encounter the Minotaur who
blocks their path
Virgil begins to mock the creature
asking if its murderer can also be found
in the circle of violence sending it
into a blind rage the Minotaur charges
and ends up severely wounded rendering
itself unable to continue giving Chase
to the poets
the first section of circle 7 is
reserved for those who committed acts of
violence against their fellow man there
is a river of boiling blood that these
Souls must Wade through every day the
level of blood one is submerged in is
dependent on the severity of the crime
those who committed murder would be
fully submerged whereas someone who
committed assault may only be submerged
partially as they approach the river
they see it's guarded by a group of
centaurs who immediately Point their
bows at Dante and Virgil demanding to
know what business they have here Virgil
then tells them he will only speak to
their leader these centaurs guard the
river not to stop individuals like Dante
and Virgil from entering but to stop The
Souls of this circle from escaping the
river itself
when Chiron notices that Dante is not
actually dead he draws his bow and
demands Virgil explains their story he
agrees for the centaurs to take the
poets to a shallow point in the river
and allow them to cross on one of these
centaur's backs the Centaur chosen for
this task is nessus which is very ironic
in itself because in Greek myth nessus
was a centaur who agreed to take
Heracles and his wife across a river
when he crossed the river with Heracles
wife he then forced himself upon her and
left Heracles no choice but to kill him
in Dante's story there is no betrayal
from nessus he does as he was instructed
and fairies the two poets across the
river
after crossing the river of blood they
walk through a wood the trees in this
wood are gnarled and twisted with no
Leaf in sight all around him Dante hears
moans and shrieks but other than the two
poets there is no one else in this word
weary that there may be Terrors hiding
Dante urges Virgil To Tread quietly but
Virgil knows where these noises are
coming from
Virgil breaks a branch off the tree and
to Dante's surprise blood pours from the
branch and the tree cries out in pain
oh why have you come to cause me pain I
was once a man just like you the second
part of this circle is reserved for
those who committed suicide
as they did not value their bodies in
life then in hell those bodies would be
taken away
everyday harpies would swoop down to
claw and feed off the trees only when
they were broken and bleeding were they
permitted to speak
Virgil explains that he meant the tree
no harm but witnessing it firsthand was
the only way Dante would believe him he
asked the tree to tell Dante his story
he was once a man named Pietro de la
Vina a diplomat under the service of
Frederick the second king of Sicily he
was a reputable man with status until he
was accused of treason and locked away
watching is his Good Fortune turned to
grief was too much for Pietro and so he
took his own life
Dante determines that this man must have
been wrongfully accused and convicted
otherwise he would have been in the
circle for traces but the fact that he
is here with others who committed
suicide means he must have been an
honest man LED down a dark path by
others and so he returns the twigs and
branches broken by Virgil and they move
on
the third part of this circle is a
desolate Barren plane where flakes of
fire fell from the sky it housed those
who committed violence against Art
nature and God
the souls found here was subjected to a
burning Heat
the blasphemers who committed crimes
against God were laid out onto the
burning sand while fire rained down on
them unable to move
The sodomites Who harm nature were left
to run around the desert through the
lava-like sand those who committed
crimes against Art were left huddled
together
all three of these groups were
perpetually screaming out in pain as the
ashy flakes fell to the ground and
caught fire leaving these Sinners to
experience an eternal burning
the two poets traveled through the
desert to waving away flakes of fire
whenever they fell near them trying
their best not to catch fire
Dante stops when he sees a man who isn't
crying out in pain the Fire doesn't seem
to bother him at all as he lays in the
sand
this man is caponeus
during the siege of Thebes he stood on a
ladder over the walls and screamed that
not even Zeus himself could stop him
entering and laying waste to the city of
course arrogance and hubris of this kind
would not be tolerated by Zeus who then
killed caponeus of a thunderbolt proving
that he could indeed stop him from
entering the city in Dante's story
kapanius is in this circle of hell for
blasphemy against Jupiter or jove the
equivalent to Zeus who also struck him
down with a bolt of thunder
he shows No Remorse for his sin as he
lay there in the burning sand cursing
the name of the God who struck him down
as they continue on they come across a
stream covered in a thick Mist which
offers them protection from the fire
above along this stream Dante is
recognized by a man who is completely
covered in Burns this man is Brunetto
latini Dante's mental and guardian when
his father passed away he asked Dante if
he may walk with him Andante eagerly
accepts suggesting that maybe they
should sit down so they can catch up
Brunetto however tells Dante that he
cannot because of his sins he must never
stop wandering the desert
so far we've only really seen political
enemies of Dante in hell but Brunetto is
one of the first Spirits he meets from
back in Florence who shares his
political beliefs he even warns him that
he faces Exile if he somehow escapes
hell and returns to Florence
they would eventually come to the end of
the stream and in front of them was the
edge of a cliff and a roaring waterfall
below Dante sees three men in front of
him that he recognizes from Florence
they asked him not to judge them based
on their burnt and scarred appearance
for they were once famous and esteemed
men
as they were guilty of sodomy they could
not stop walking and so they formed a
circle around Dante asking him of the
current political situation in Florence
a question that leaves Dante with an
expression of grief
he then tells them the story of his
journey and they wish him luck if he
ever escapes hell they ask her only that
he speaks of them favorably
as they look down into the abyss below
Virgil asked Dante to throw the belt he
wore around his waist over the edge and
wait they are now approaching the eighth
circle of hell a strange shape that
Dante can't quite make out Rises From
Below and stops before them behold the
Beast or the pointed tail that crosses
mountains leaves walls and weapons
broken and makes the stench of which the
world is full
the creature answers Virgil's call and
makes itself visible
a creature with human beastial and
reptilian elements all combined into one
its name is Gary on
a winged monster with a face of a man a
scorpid stinger and the body that is
part Beast part reptile its General
shape can be compared to that of a
wyvern with some elements of a chimera
or manticore
in Greek myth garyon is a three-headed
giant but here Dante's garyon is an
amalgamation of three separate beings
and is a visual representation of the
next Circle
the friendly human face makes him seem
trustworthy but his grotesque body and
Stinger present us with the idea of a
trickster or fraudster behind the
pleasant face is a cold-blooded monster
Virgil explains the only way down this
waterfall is on the creature's back but
he makes sure that he sits behind Dante
and warns him to be wary of Gary on
Stinger those who are not wary of his
true nature never make it to the bottom
of this Abyss
the eighth circle of hell is fraud for
those who committed fraudulent and
malicious crimes this circle is also
known as the Mali Bulger meaning the
ditches of evil this also refers to the
layout of the circle as it's divided
into ten narrow ditches each one
punishing a different Act of fraud
the first Stitch contains seduces and
panderers a fancy name for a Pimp or
someone who owns a brothel these two
groups lined the walls of this ditch
walking in opposite directions being
whipped by horned demons
at first this may not seem like a harsh
punishment but these demons can be seen
as symbolic of slave drivers just as
these men chose to treat women like
objects that could be disposed of and
sold in the afterlife they would be
nothing more than a commodity themselves
to these demonic slave drivers
Dante recognizes one man as venedico who
he recalls arranged the sale of his own
sister to a nobleman
on the other side Virgil points out a
man named Jason Jason of Argo the once
famous hero Jason is there for the
seduction of the Sorceress Medea which
to be fair had more to do with Athena
and Hera trying to help him but he did
also seduce the queen of lemnos and then
sail away after she had two of his
children so for that douchebaggery Jason
is condemned to an eternity in hell
next to this trench are those considered
guilty of false flattery exploiting
others fears and desires by twisting and
corrupting language to manipulate them
these individuals are covered in their
own feces which represent the falsehoods
they told whilst alive they do nothing
but ride around and howl at each other
not a sight Dante and Virgil were keen
on observing for very long
in the third ditch Dante finds those
guilty of simony gaining position in the
Christian church due to monetary means
or through other favors this term comes
from Simon Magnus a magician or sorcerer
who tried to pay Saint Peter to bestow
the power of the Holy Spirit upon him
the simonics as they are referred to
were placed headfirst into holes with
flames burning the soles of their feet
Dante notices one pair of feet squirming
more than the others because the Flames
are much higher this Soul was Pope
Nicholas III who mistakes Dante for the
then Pope Bonifacio he explains to Dante
that because he tried to abuse his
position in the church he must serve a
lifetime in this hole and Below him are
all the other popes guilty of the same
crime when the next Pope dies he will
take his place at the very top pushing
Pope Nicholas further down the hole like
all those before him the corruption of
the church by the Simon ax is something
Dante makes very clear he despises which
is why we see it so deep into hell
in the fourth hole were the sorcerers
who dabbled in divination fortune
telling and astrology Arts that were
associated with a false prophet the
punishment for being a sorcerer was
having their head twisted backwards
leaving them to slowly walk forward and
only being able to look back at the
other hideous distorted sorcerers
in the fifth hole were the baratas also
known as grifters
these Souls were immersed in a lake of
boiling tar A visual representation of
their Shady dealings and sticky fingers
they are also guarded by winged demons
known as the malibrangier
when a grifter tries to emerge from the
surface they Claw at them and attack
them with hooks until they are once
again fully submerged for some reason
Dante ends up insulting these demons
which results in them being pursued they
eventually Escape down a slope where
they encounter hole number six
these men are dressed in what appear to
be regular robes but judging by how
slowly they're moving and the discomfort
in their face this isn't true these
robes are weighed down by lead on the
outside everything looks fine these
robes appear just as you would expect
from any holy man but the weight inside
is symbolic of the weight one carries
with them in lies and deceit
Dante and Virgil climb across a ruined
bridge and stand above pit number seven
this hole is full of naked people being
chased by snakes and lizards their hands
are bound behind their backs with snakes
these souls are the thieves
those who stole in life will now have
everything stolen from them their
possessions their identity and their
Humanity
Dante finds one man willing to tell him
his story Vani fuchi a man who stole
holy items from a cathedral who
committed violent crimes and murder
as they talk a Viper bites his neck and
kills Vani only for him to burst into
flames and resurrect From the Ashes Like
a Phoenix
the Vani shares a prophecy with Dante
that all those Dante aligns with back in
Florence shall die including Dante
as the snake attacks him again Vani
curses the gods and flees from Dante
after this a centaur arrives with a
fire-breathing dragon on his shoulder
and he asks where the bitter one has
gone implying that he is there to punish
Vani
Dante wonders why the other centaurs in
Hell watch over the river of blood but
this one known as cassus finds himself
with the other thieves Virgil explains
that this is because cassus was killed
by Heracles when he tried to steal his
cattle so although centaurs by Nature
are violent this one was also a thief
they also observe quite a disturbing
process where a snake with feet bites a
man and then the two begin to merge
together and mutate into one creature
with body parts from both another snake
bites a man and smoke pours from his
wound and the snake's mouth this time
the two swap places and mutate into each
other the man's body shrinks and
distorts until he becomes a snake and
the snake subsequently becomes a man
giving us the impression that everything
in this hole may be a thief even these
snakes and lizards we thought existed in
the hole to punish the thieves
in hole 8 Dante sees the fraudulent
counselors who are literally burning in
a pit of flames for their sins these are
individuals who use their positions to
convince and manipulate others to engage
in fraud
here we notice two heroes in particular
Odysseus and diomedes who were held
accountable for the idea of the Trojan
Horse as well as numerous other failings
that led to the fall of Troy the ninth
hole was dedicated to the Sowers of
Discord those who tried to create
divisions between people
when Dante looks down into the pit he
struggles to find words to describe what
he sees those guilty of creating these
divisions were being hacks Away by a
demon wielding a large blood-stained
sword
their bodies were torn into pieces
entrails were dragged along the floor
and most bodies no longer even resembled
a human shape
just as they sought to tear others apart
in life in death their bodies are
physically torn apart and mutilated
Dante eventually describes this by
saying if you gathered all the people
who were injured in the bloodiest and
most grotesque battles their wounds and
injuries could still not match the
mutilation that took place in the ninth
hole
when their bodies were torn apart they
would drag themselves around this hole
regenerating once a full circuit was
complete the demon would then tear them
apart again and this cycle would repeat
for eternity
Dante unable to shake what he saw from
his mind approach the 10th and final
Hull
from this hole came a horrendous stench
bodies were scattered around laying on
top of each other disease ridden and
writhing
these bodies belong to the falsifiers
the Alchemists the counterfeiters and
the imposters
just as they were a plague on Humanity
in life they experienced every plague in
disease possible
Dante noticed some of them were covered
in leporous scabs
furiously scratching until there was no
flesh remaining
after everything Dante has seen and been
through he finally approaches a giant
well the entrance to the final circle of
hell the circle of treachery
outside they see numerous Giants one
blowing on a horn that was Nimrod who
built the Tower of Babel in Hell however
he is incapable of coherent speech next
to him is a much larger Giant in Chains
Felts who was punished for his Uprising
against jove this is referring to the
gigantomaki where the Giants try to
storm Olympus leading this Army against
Zeus was Felts another giant who isn't
in Chains is antaus and it's this giant
who places both poets in the palm of his
hand and carries them down to the Ninth
Circle
and so the last part of Dante's Journey
Through Hell begins in a circle he
describes as the bottom of the universe
full of treachery and betrayal
at the very bottom they come across
another Lake but there is no blood or
Tar this lake has frozen over
it spans almost the entirety of the
circle and is divided into four sections
with the Sinners being trapped in the
ice itself these are known as the
betrayers of family community the guest
and Lords
Dante then describes two immediate
regions the first is known as Cana which
is referring to the biblical figure Cain
who kills his own brother no surprise
this area houses those who betrayed
their family these Sinners are not fully
submerged in the ice they can still move
their heads but nothing else
Dante sees two bodies Frozen so close
together that their foreheads are almost
glued by the cold and he recognizes them
as two brothers who murdered each other
over a dispute involving family
inheritance
the second area is known as antinora
named after the Trojan Soldier and tenor
who betrayed his people to the Greeks
this area housed those who committed
treason and betrayed their country and
Community as Dante continues across this
Lake he accidentally kicks someone in
the head and they shout back asking why
do you trample me
the bodies in this area are submerged in
a similar way to the previous the main
difference being they can't move their
neck
the man who Dante kicked was someone who
betrayed Florence Andante gives this man
no apology or sympathy the third region
in this icy Wasteland is Ptolemy named
after a man who invited his
father-in-law to dinner only to kill him
Dante stumbles upon a man who asked him
if he can remove the ice from his eyes
the man then explains that after
murdering a guest the soul falls into
ptolemyer long before the body dies the
empty body is then inhabited by a demon
until a natural death occurs so their
suffering begins long before they
actually die the fourth area of this
lake is known as judeka of course being
named after Judas and those who betrayed
the Lord
those in judeca are fully encased in the
ice and as a result not a sound is made
as there is no one to speak to the poets
move quickly on to the center of Hell
Virgil tells Dante that the banner of
the king of Hell draws closer meaning
there is only one Soul left to observe
when they reach the very center Dante is
frozen to the spot and no words can be
formed in the very center of Hell Satan
is condemned for the worst act of all
treachery against God himself
it's explained here that his name was
once Lucifer the fairest of the angels
in heaven but his Rebellion against God
led to him being cast from heaven and
frozen in ice from the waist down Dante
struggles to comprehend how big
Lucifer's body really is only being able
to see the upper half which is free from
Ice
what's more stunning than his size is
the fact that he has three heads one
that is fiery red one that is pale
yellow
and one that is black
underneath each head are a pair of
bat-like wings which have been flapping
and causing the icy winds Dante and
Virgil experienced while crossing the
lake These Wings Are also to ensure the
lake stays Frozen so Satan and everybody
else can never leave this prison
Satan himself cannot speak but only cry
and blubber into his mouth each mouth is
also constantly chewing on a treacherous
man Marcus Junius Brutus and Gaius
Cassius longinus two men responsible for
the assassination of Julius Caesar hang
from the left and right mouths
in the center mouth hangs Judas punished
for his betrayal of Jesus Christ Judah
suffered the worst punishment as he
represented treason against the Divine
whereas the others were guilty of
treason against man
Virgil tells Dante that now is when they
escape Hell by climbing down Lucifer
himself
which makes no sense to Dante as surely
that would only take them deeper into
hell Virgil assures him that this is the
only way and so they climb down Satan's
legs once they reach his genitalia they
pass through the center of the universe
Virgil turns his body around and then
starts climbing back up which again
makes no sense to Dante as that's the
way they just came from as Dante follows
Virgil he's amazed to see everything is
essentially upside down and they are now
climbing up Lucifer's legs Virgil
explains that they are essentially
climbing up through the crater left by
Lucifer when he crashed into the Earth
they eventually climb out of hell on the
morning of Easter Sunday and before them
is the river Lethy which flows from the
mountain of purgatory
[Music]
before we begin a brief explanation into
the idea of purgatory itself May provide
some context
the Bible doesn't really mention
Purgatory at least not by name but it
does mention that one's punishment after
death may not always be Eternal in some
cases it may only be temporary once your
debt has been repaid there is hope of
one day joining others in Paradise
to explain as simply as possible both
hell and Paradise are what Dante
considers
Eternal Realms Purgatory is different as
it's the only realm that is not Eternal
those who come here may not be ready for
hell or Paradise instead they are given
the chance to cleanse their sins and
grow as a person
when it's time for the last judgment all
the souls in purgatory will be sent to
either hell or paradise and the realm of
purgatory will cease to exist entirely
at the base of the mountain Dante and
Virgil meet an old man named Cato who
guards the entrance naturally he's
hesitant to let them pass not entirely
sure how Dante and Virgil were able to
Escape From Hell Virgil explains the
journey thus far and how it would only
be possible for them to escape if God
himself allowed them to
Kato is persuaded and allows them to
pass
but only if Virgil raps a read Around
Dante and washes his face a ritual many
Soros representing a baptism
an interesting thing to note is that
Kato is what we described before as a
virtuous Pagan who was placed in
purgatory by God himself which is rather
strange because not only could he be
found in the first circle of hell but he
also committed suicide I've seen many
discussing the significance of Cato in
purgatory so why would Dante Place Kato
here in purgatory and not in hell
it could be because Kato was as
patriotic as Dante and would do anything
to defend Rome's Liberty or maybe Dante
was just fond of Kato and decided he
shouldn't suffer
in the first circle of hell souls are
ferried across the river by The Boatman
Caron some of them crying and others
were the looks of worry and anguish on
their face here they are ferry to the
foot of the mountain by an Angel while
singing songs of Hope and joy
when they arrive at the shore the angel
disappears and the crowd gathers around
Dante realizing he's not actually dead
luckily Kato breaks up the crowd and
orders them to disperse
the two stand at the base of the
mountain deciding how they will begin
their climb as a group of souls pass by
the first two sections of the mountain
are known as anti-purgatory the first
slope is where they find the X
communicate those who are excluded or
exiled from the Christian Church the
time they spent away from the church
living in sin would be multiplied by 30
so if they spent even just one year
excommunicated they would have to remain
here for 30. the most noticeable figure
they meet here is Manfred the last king
of Sicily who tells them the story of
his death
during the Battle of benevento he
suffered multiple fatal wounds whilst he
lay on the battlefield dying he managed
to repent for all of his sins
unfortunately for Manfred his opposition
Pope Clement IV had his body
excommunicated after death which led to
the belief that he was going to hell
Manfred then explains that the prayers
of the living can help reduce the time
one spends in purgatory naturally he
asked Dante to find his daughter when he
returns to let her know her father is
not in hell but in purgatory if she
prays for him he may reach Paradise
quicker
before reaching The Terraces there is
still one more part of anti-purgatory
for those who were too late or too lazy
to repent many of these Souls died
before receiving the last rites because
they suffered a violent or unpredictable
death Dante comes across a group of
souls laying in the shadow of a boulder
and decides to have a conversation the
first man tells him he was betrayed when
fleeing his hometown
the second man was fleeing a battle when
he fell down a riverbed and died after
repenting the man recalls an angel
coming to collect him but there was also
a demon they argued whether he belonged
in Hell or paradise and that is why he
now finds himself in purgatory the last
Spirit was a woman named Pia de ptolemae
she tells Dante of her murder at the
hands of her husband who betrayed her
and disregarded their wedding vows she
also attempts to convince Dante to pray
for her once he returns to the living
because none of her family do so and she
would like to leave Purgatory Dante
begins to notice how interested all the
souls in purgatory are in himself or
more so the fact that he is not dead
meaning he can pray for them and reduce
the time they spend here
the next Soul they meet is sordello a
performer from the same town as Virgil
who explains the rule of the mountain
once the sun has set the souls of
purgatory are no longer allowed to climb
they can go down if they wish to rest
but never the other way you can look at
the Sun as an allegory for God meaning
these Souls can only progress in their
penitent Christian Life through his
divine grace
as it is getting late in the afternoon
they move on and find a spot to rest
sordello recommends they should stop for
the night in the valley of princes
as Darkness engulfs the valley the
spirits sing hymns you would hear during
night prayer in Christian churches
sodello shows them the various Kings and
rulers who reside here making notes of
Emperor Rudolph the only Soul who
refuses to join in on the singing he
also regards him as the one ruler who
could have restored Italy to its former
glory but he failed and that is why he
finds himself here as the night goes on
the spirits here do not Tire as they do
not possess a human body Dante however
does and so he must sleep
in his dream Dante sees a golden eagle
soaring through the sky it swoops down
and grabs Dante and while they fly
through the air they begin to burn this
was enough for Dante to wake from his
dream
Virgil explains that they are now at the
Gate of purgatory whilst Dante dreamed
he was carried to the gates by a woman
named Lucia this is referring to Saint
Lucia or Saint Lucy
in front of them is the gate the door to
Purgatory proper before the gate there
are three steps each one a different
color one is a polished White marble so
bright Dante can see himself in the
reflection this represents the purity of
one's Soul the next stone is cracked and
much darker either black or purple in
the shape of a cross which represents
the act of mourning
the last stone is red which represents
the blood of Christ restoration and a
new beginning at the top of these steps
there is an angel guarding the entrance
wielding a large sword an angel who
shines so bright it's difficult for
Dante to even look at him Virgil
explains they have been guided upon this
patch by Saint Lucy and he urges Dante
to step forward and ask the angel to let
him pass
Dante opts for the more dramatic
approach as he climbs the steps he falls
to his knees at the feet of the Angel
and begs for entry into purgatory
looking down at Dante the Angel takes
the point of his sword and carves the
letter P into Dante's forehead seven
times the P meaning pecatum the Latin
for sin
he tells Dante he may wash these wounds
away as he travels through the seven
Terraces each time he has successfully
washed away the sins of a Terrace one
letter will disappear
the last piece of advice they are given
is to cleanse themselves of their sins
and never look back or dwell on the past
as they may struggle to move on to the
next Terrace
with the gates closing behind them The
Poets are left to climb the seven
Terraces each one representing one of
the seven deadly sins
Pride Envy wrath sloth avarice gluttony
and lust
the sins we saw an inferno were based on
physical actions in purgatory the focus
is on self-improvement and so the sins
are emotional and psychological
the first Terrace represents the sin of
pride
as they enter Dante notices beautiful
sculptures surrounding him which
represented humility The Virtue
considered the opposite of Pride these
images were of individuals who were
considered classic examples of humility
such as the Virgin Mary and the angel
Gabriel
Virgil pulls Dante away from the
beautiful sculptures and paintings
because in front of them are the
prideful Souls who can guide them to the
next Terrace
these souls are barely visible as they
are hunched over forced to carry
enormous weights on their back
they asked the man before them if he can
help them travel up the mountain the man
physically cannot look upwards but he
tells them he will offer his assistance
his name is Umberto a man who was so
proud it led to his death his arrogance
caused himself and his family much pain
but now he is slowly learning to be
humble
ahead of him is another man odorisi a
once famous artist who was replaced by a
much younger artist he now understands
that in the bigger picture human Fame
means nothing success and fame are
fleeting as Dante talks to these souls
he finds himself bending over to see
their faces in doing so he is imitating
their suffering and starting his own
cleansing process as they continue on
Dante realizes that pride is a sin he
has been guilty of his self-awareness is
another sign of self-improvement
when he looks down he sees several
hideous statues and carvings Lucifer
falling from the heavens Arachne who was
turned into a spider and briarius a
giant impaled on a thunderbolt these
figures all represent the acts of
succumbing to Pride or one's ego as he
Witnesses more Dante remembers instances
where his own pride has clouded his
judgment
agreeing to pray for the souls in this
Terrace they show him the path he must
follow
when they arrive standing before them is
the angel of humility he takes them to
the stairway that leads to the next
Terrace and acknowledges that Dante's
prideful sins have been absolved with
his wing he brushes off one of the
letter p's from Dante's forehead as they
leave this Terrace they hear songs of
joy and Dante points out the difference
between this and the screams in Hell
whenever they entered a new Circle
he also notices he feels lighter making
the ascent slightly easier than before
Virgil explains that this is because his
sins of Pride have been cleansed and as
this process continues the journey will
become easier the second Harris is that
of Envy once their dantean Virgil notice
no one else around them and so Virgil
uses the Sun as a compass to guide them
when they eventually come across other
Souls Dante notices they are dressed in
black and blue matching the color of the
stone in this Terrace
as they approach they hear these Souls
singing and holding on to each other it
is now Dante sees their true punishment
the reason their hands rest on the
shoulders of the soul in front of them
is because they are blind their eyelids
have been sewn shut using iron wire this
site is enough to bring Dante to tears
as he is reminded of the blind begging
on the streets despite Virgil's
disapproval Dante still feels the need
to speak of them and so he asks if any
are from Italy a woman named Sapia
responds telling him she often received
more enjoyment from The Misfortune of
others than her own Good Fortune she was
extremely envious of those in power when
she questions Dante as to who he is and
why he's still alive he tells her he
will pass through this Terrace and only
be momentarily blinded because he felt
he was more prideful than envious sapi
agree is to guide them through the
Terrace in exchange for Dante's prayers
back on Earth
tadante's Amusement two souls in front
of him argue amongst each other before
they notice him observing one of which
tells him he was jealous of his
neighbor's happiness and his Envy only
grew as time went on as they continued
Dante hears the booming of several
different voices these are the envious
who were punished serving as examples
for the rest of the souls to learn from
some examples given were Kane who was
jealous of his brother and aglarus who
was turned into stone because she was
jealous Hermes loved her sister more
than her in order to pass through this
terrorist Dante and Virgil must walk
where the sun shines bright and as they
do they are blinded mimicking the
punishment of those in this Terrace
Virgil explains that Dante should not
fear this light because it is merely an
angel coming to welcome them to the next
Terrace the angel of Charity greets them
and brushes away another Sin from
Dante's forehead inviting them to move
on
as The Poets enter the Terrace of Wrath
the blinding sunlight is still apparent
Dante is then greeted by several Visions
examples of meekness and wrath the first
vision is in a temple with a woman
reprimanding a young boy this is meant
to represent a similar story featuring
the Virgin Mary and a young Jesus Christ
the next vision is the wife of the king
of Athens begging him to kill the man
who loves their daughter his response is
no if they condemn those around them for
showing love then they will soon be
their enemies
the last vision is of a boy who prays
for his persecutors to be forgiven by
God as they Stone him to death
when Dante comes to he explains what he
has seen to Virgil hoping this will
start the process of cleansing his own
sins relating to Wrath the current time
is 3 P.M The Poets continue to follow
the light up the mountain until they are
surrounded by black smoke which now
blinds them Dante Compares himself to a
blind man being Guided by Virgil unable
to see Dante hears more singing One
Voice calls out to Dante recognizing
that he's alive and in response Dante
and Virgil ask for directions the spirit
agrees and tells the poets to listen
carefully because their voices are the
only way to keep track of each other
within the smoke
the spirit's name is Marco Lombardo
Dante asks him why he believes there is
wickedness in the world
Marco explains he thinks it's because of
the belief that Humanity has no free
will when something terrible happens
people look to the heavens as the cause
the action must have been preordained by
God but Marco believes we must have free
will over some actions otherwise the
reward and Punishment system of Heaven
and Hell makes no sense you can't punish
or reward someone for an action they are
not responsible for that being said
Marco believes he came from a time where
the morals of men were much greater than
Dante's present day eventually the smoke
begins to clear and this is Marco's cue
to leave before the angel of this
Terrace arrives
before leaving Dante has several more
visions that represent the sin of Wrath
he's woken by Virgil as the sun shines
bright on them
from the light they hear a voice telling
them it's time to ascend to the next
Terrace as Dante approaches intrigued as
to the source of this beautiful voice he
is once again blinded The Voice they
hear is the angel of this Terrace who
has come to guide them as they climb the
steps to the next Terrace the angel
removes another Sin from Dante and gives
them a Blessing by the time they leave
this Terrace night falls upon them as
they enter Terrace number four Dante
asks Virgil which Vice is to be cleansed
than this Terrace the answer to that
question is sloth
now this doesn't necessarily mean
physical laziness but more of a
spiritual laziness or neglect that would
lead to someone being sad and depressed
Virgil explains sloth by using love as
an example he states there are two types
of love we can choose what or who to
love and whether we love them too little
or too much these are mistakes we can
make the second type of Love Is Love
towards God himself which can never be a
mistake if your love for God is your
priority then you can never succumb to
evil however this changes when your love
for God takes a back seat
in Virgil's worldview love is the
driving force for all of our actions and
decisions all of our vices and virtues
stem from love those guilty of sloth in
this case have given up on the pursuit
of love and have turned their backs on
God and their own happiness
most of the spirits in this Terrace
don't have much time to talk to Dante
and so Virgil guides him through how to
cleanse this Vice
as the night goes on Dante decides to
get some rest and Begins the dream about
a beautiful woman this woman is actually
a siren the siren here is a symbol of
gluttony and lust Dante is seduced by
the siren song he doesn't notice the
arrival of a second woman who is dressed
much more saintly this woman doesn't
seem too happy that Virgil allowed this
situation to happen realizing his
mistake Virgil runs over to the siren
and tears off her clothes
rather than being in awe of the naked
woman in front of him Dante snaps out of
his trance he smells the sirens putrid
stench and foul appearance
he now sees her true nature
when Dante wakes they hurry to the
entrance of the next Terrace and there
to greet them is the angel of zeal
having proven himself in his dream the
angel brushes off another sin and shows
them passage to the next Terrace
the last three Terraces are devoted to
those who either misplace their love or
show too much they are The Terraces of
avarice gluttony and lust Terrace number
five relates to the vice of avarice
meaning Greed for physical goods and
extravagance all the ambition to gain
power and social standing as they pass
through this Terrace they see the
penitent Souls lying face down on the
ground in Chains weeping when they ask
for directions they are told if they do
not share a similar punishment then they
should look to the path on the right
the first Soul Dante speaks to is Pope
Adrian V who is here because of his
ambition for political power within the
church eventually he began to lose
interest in his mortal life and so he
began to focus on the afterlife which is
why he finds himself here and not in
hell they continue down the path when
they hear a female voice calling out to
them she describes Mary giving birth to
Jesus in a stable as an example of how
poor she was this becomes common with
other Souls discussing their stories of
poverty soon The Poets realized the
waiter cleanse the sin of greed is with
generosity Dante begins to hear more
stories of generosity as opposed to
avarice
fabricius was a Roman politician who
refused to take bribes that would have
furthered his own position he then hears
several stories of someone who gave
money to poor women so they could afford
to get married
the next Soul Dante comes across is Hugh
Cape a king of France who shares some of
his stories he also tells Dante the
souls in this terrorist discuss acts of
generosity during the day and sins of
avarice during the night
all of a sudden the Earth begins to
shake and only Dante and Virgil seem
concerned so they take this as a sign to
make Haste The Last Man they come across
is compared to Jesus Christ shortly
after his resurrection Dante and Virgil
here are the two disciples he meets on
the road when he questions who they are
Virgil explains that Dante was meant to
reign with the righteous but he has
fallen off his path and it is Virgil's
job to guide him
the man is Overjoyed hearing this mostly
because he's a big fan of Virgil's work
The Man reveals himself as the Roman
poet statius the Tremor they felt
earlier only happens when a soul is
ready to ascend to Paradise on this
occasion the Tremor is because of status
statius explains it was the work of
Virgil that inspired him to change his
ways
the three are then greeted by the angel
of moderation who removes another of
Dante's sins and ushers them to the next
Terrace estatius himself will be moving
through The Terraces he decides to join
Dante and Virgil on their Journey
Terrace number six is where those guilty
of gluttony resign as somebody who's
covered the story of Tantalus within
Greek mythology a few times what comes
next is a very nice reference the souls
in this terrorists experience a
punishment very similar to Tantalus
Eternal hunger and thirst
in front of them is a large tree ripe
with fruit and below a pool of water as
they approach they begin to hear voices
telling stories of temperance The Virtue
Dante will need to purge his gluttony
John the Baptist chose to eat Locust and
honey when he was in the wilderness and
the Virgin Mary cared more about her
guests than herself Dante is unable to
place where the voices are coming from
but it seems as if they may be coming
from the tree itself before he can be
tempted by the fruit Virgil urges Dante
to continue on the path ahead of them
now they finally see the souls that
reside in this Terrace Dante is
horrified by how starved and skinny they
are their skeletons are almost
completely visible again Dante begins to
hear voices warning him this tree
represents the tree of knowledge that
Eve ate from In the Garden of Eden they
also begin to tell stories of gluttony
the stories continue as they walk on
eventually they come to a halt when they
see a red light
this is the angel of temperance who
shows them the path they must not stray
from as Dante was able to avoid
Temptation he had shown enough
Temperance or self-restraint for the
angel to remove the sin of gluttony
Now we move on to Terrace number seven
where the lustful reside
to enter this Terrace one must pass
through a giant wall of Fire
our poets tread carefully before
reaching the wall here they see other
Souls Walking Through the flames and
giving examples of lust one of them
being the cities of Sodom and Gomorrah
cities that were mentioned in the Book
of Genesis those repenting here do so
for acts of inappropriate and
misdirected sexual desire to purge
themselves of this sin they look towards
the Virgin Mary and chastity
as the sun begins to set the poets are
greeted by the angel of Chastity who
urges them to proceed through the fire
but Dante remains Frozen to the spot
Virgil persuades him that there is
nothing to fear unlike hell there is no
chance of death here with this Dante
shows his faith in God as well as in
Virgil who has led him this far he steps
forward and passes through the wall of
Fire
on the other side they are greeted by
another set of steps which they choose
to rest on until sunrise when light
breaks Dante and his two guides climb to
the very top here Virgil congratulates
him Dante is now free he no longer needs
a guide
he urges Dante to go ahead and explore
the Earthly Paradise on his own
we then have one final verse from Virgil
Waits no further word or sign from me
your will is free erect and whole to act
against that will would be to ER
therefore I crown and mighty you over
yourself
Dante is free from purgatory but he
doesn't know these are the last words he
will ever hear from the man he considers
his guide mentor and friend
at the very top of Mount Purgatory sits
the Earthly Paradise which is pretty
much the Garden of Eden a vibrant Forest
full of greenery and Lush surroundings
that embody the Peace of Eden before
Adam and Eve fell from Greece
the Earthly Paradise kantos are
notoriously difficult to completely
understand because much of it is
symbolism this is where Dante must
confess all of his sins
the first person Dante comes across is a
young woman holding flowers singing by a
riverbed when he gets closer he
recognizes a song similar to one sung by
demita when her daughter Persephone
leaves for the underworld during the
winter
Dante is confused as to why all of a
sudden he can feel the wind on his
cheeks as statius told him Purgatory
does not experience weather the woman
explains that as the Garden of Eden is
where Humanity committed the original
sin things here work slightly
differently
she also mentions the waters here have
special properties the power to make one
forget all of their previous sins or
remember all of the Good Deeds they have
done
when Dante turns around both of his
companions are there smiling
a bright flash of light passes through
the forest and when Dante regains his
sight he sees what appears to be seven
trees in the distance as he gets close
he realizes the trees form a candelabra
and the Flames from the candles like the
sky the lights are closely followed by a
group of people all dressed in white
Dante describes 24 Elders dressed in
white with crowns made from lilies
behind their Elders are four animals
wearing crowns made of green leaves each
with six wings feathers full of eyes
behind the animals is a chariot being
pulled by a griffin on the right side
there are three dancing women one
dressed in red one in emerald and the
third in white on the other side there
are four more women dressed in dark red
or purple behind the Chariots there are
seven men two elderly men four humble
men and one man walking alone
much of the Divine Comedy at times feels
like a lucid dream and you'd be forgiven
for reading this description and having
no idea what is actually happening it
may not be entirely comparable but
processions relating to the church were
fairly common in the Roman Empire
everything we see in this ritual is
symbolic of something else much of it
borrowing from the New and Old Testament
as The Chariot comes to a halt Angels
rise and cast flowers into the air from
which emerges a woman in a red dress and
white veil with a crown of olive
branches
Dante recognizes this as Beatrice when
he turns to Virgil to tell him he was
right his friend is no longer there
Beatrice symbolizes the path of God that
Dante must follow Virgil if you remember
from Inferno resides in the circle for
virtuous pagans he wasn't necessarily a
bad person he just didn't believe in God
in hell and Purgatory Virgil's guidance
was needed but now Dante must Ascend to
heaven and for that he needs a True
Believer and so we see Virgil past the
torch to Beatrice
Dante sheds a tear for his friend who
has taken him this far but Beatrice
tells him to cry no more because of
Virgil's disappearance the Earthly
Paradise is no place for Tears or sorrow
Dante confesses to Beatrice then after
her death he turned to material
belongings to distract himself from his
pain
she then admonishes him claiming her
death should have had the opposite
effects
she continues to push Dante to confess
his sinful actions and he does so
feeling more and more shame
eventually Beatrice removes her veil and
Dante is so taken back by everything he
just faints
when he wakes he finds himself being
placed in the river leithy by a young
woman who along with statius takes him
back to Beatrice this is the process of
forgetting one's memories of past sin
the next River he comes to is the river
you know which Dante must shrink from in
order to restore his memories of all the
good deeds he has done
Dante is now ready to ascend to paradise
and the final Kanto ends of these words
from that most holy wave I now return to
Beatrice remade
as new trees are renewed when they bring
forth new bows I was pure and prepared
to climb unto the Stars
having escaped the events of Inferno
With His companion and friend Virgil
together they were also able to complete
the ascent of Mount Purgatory however
with Virgil's job complete he passes the
Reigns to Beatrice who will accompany
and guide Dante through heaven or
Paradise hence the name Paradiso so far
you may have noticed some patterns
forming in Inferno there were Nine
Circles each one representing different
sins this journey was about punishment
and acknowledgment of one sin in
purgatory there were 9 or 10 Terraces
each one representing a sin but also a
virtue that can cleanse the sin the
focus here is on repentance and
cleansing one's Soul a clean slate for
heaven Paradise consists of nine spheres
with each one representing different
celestial bodies and virtues the Earth
is at the very center of the universe
surrounded by these nine spheres as
Dante travels to each one Beatrice will
help him understand the theology or
concepts Behind these ideas with each
sphere his comprehension grows and his
Consciousness expands once he has
absorbed the knowledge from the nine
spheres he will gain access to the
empyrion the highest Heaven and the home
of God similar to Purgatory where there
were nine Terraces with the Earthly
Paradise at the very Peak we see the
same nine plus one solution in Paradise
nine Heavenly spheres with number 10
being the empyrean the final layer of
Heaven
the poem begins in the Earthly Paradise
at the very top of Mount Purgatory
Dante's journey through Paradise had
taken 24 hours meaning he had ascended
from Hell To Paradise in about one week
total Dante and Beatrice begin their
Ascent through the atmosphere when Dante
questions how this is even possible
Beatrice explains that one's soul is
naturally drawn towards God now that he
has freed himself from his Earthly
desires his soul is able to soar freely
towards God and Heaven the first
Heavenly sphere is the moon representing
the inconstant Dante questions the dark
markings on the moon's surface that we
can see from the earth and Beatrice lets
him come to his own conclusion here they
end up having a scientific debate about
the concentration of matter and light
however this is cut short when he has a
vision of nearby Souls that he confused
uses for Reflections Beatrice explains
that the lunar cycle and how much we can
see of the moon is associated with
inconsistency the sphere of the moon is
made up of the souls who abandon their
vow to God for numerous reasons they
lacked what Beatrice describes as the
virtue of fortitude these Souls have all
still been saved and have access to all
the Spheres in heaven but Dante's
perception of them is limited as he is
still mortal Dante has a conversation
with the soul of picada the sister of
one of Dante's friends picardo died
shortly after being forcibly removed
from her Convent by evil men her vow to
God that was broken and though it was
not entirely her fault she did not
completely resist showing a lack of
fortitude Beatrice explains that a vow
to God consists of giving yourself
freely and into entirely these vowels
should be taken very seriously and
everything should be done to maintain
the vowel one must remain consistent in
their conviction Dante wonders if there
is a way one can atone for broken
promises Beatrice explains that God's
greatest gift is Free Will and pledging
yourself to God is essentially you
giving up that gift however the church
does have the ability to release people
from their vows through one loophole
when one makes a vowel a certain amount
of worth can be established to that
promise if you then make another vow
that the church deems to be of higher
value than Naval is not broken but
simply adjusted now if your initial
vowel is seen as Priceless then this
cannot be amended as there is no higher
value the only exception to this is when
keeping a vowel would result in a
greater evil Dante uses k King
agamemnon's willingness to sacrifice his
own daughter in the Trojan War as an
example of when a vowel can descend too
far towards evil
the second sphere is the planet Mercury
the representation of the ambitious who
desired Fame and Glory those who are
lacking in the virtue of Justice Mercury
being so close to the Sun makes it hard
to see it pales in comparison to the
sun's Glory just as the Earth pales in
comparison to the glory of God here
Dante meets the Roman Emperor Justinian
who narrates the vast majority of this
Kanto Justinian realizes that in heaven
who he is as a person Remains the Same
however the glory he so eagerly seek to
acquire on Earth is gone he talks about
the great history and conquests of the
Roman Empire but acknowledges that this
sphere is for those who place to
self-interest above all we hear tales of
the Roman emperor Constantine who
committed the crime of moving the
capital of the Roman Empire from Rome to
Byzantium or Constantinople which two
justinians symbolize the Empire turning
its back on God and hundreds of years of
good leadership Justinian then explains
that when Rome was under his rule years
later he was able to reform the laws
allowing Rome to find peace once again
he was only able to do so because he was
converted to Christianity he then makes
the point that there are many who
pretend to support the Roman Church
publicly but behind closed doors are
actually opposed to it the third sphere
is the planet Venus the sphere of lovers
because of its association with Venus
the Roman deity of love this is where
those lacking Temperance or
self-restraint reside Dante himself
starts to feel its effects as when he
turns to Beatrice he finds her even more
more beautiful than before Dante meets
Charles Martel who believes he would
have led Italy to new heights and
created Harmony amongst his people if he
had not died so early the rest of the
Martell family caused disaster and
disharmony Charles explains that one's
family does not decide Destiny nor human
nature that is down to the Providence of
God Dante speaks to some other Souls who
warn him of the dangers of love and its
corruption within the Church Florence
used as a prime example of what happens
to a city devoid of temperance
sphere number four is the sun the sphere
of the wise here Dante enjoys and bathes
in the light there are only positive
examples of the previous virtues here
the sun illuminates the rest of the
universe just as those who reside here
illuminate the world with their
intellect this sphere is full of
Scholars religious leaders and the
wisest philosophers among those Dante
meats are Thomas Aquinas King Solomon
Peter Lombard and many more Aquinas
explains that creation is completely
random because of how matter is filtered
and trickles down from the different
spheres hence why no two people are the
same the only exceptions to this are
Christ and Adam who were created
directly by God and therefore must be
perfect by Design Dante also sees Bright
Lights which represent different Saints
orders that mean not have seen eye to
eye on Earth or even agreed with each
other's ideas here they are at peace
with each other and only show love even
to those of an opposing faction sphere
number five is the planet Mars which as
with Venus is associated with Mars the
Roman God of War Mars is home to what
Dante describes as the Warriors of faith
those who died giving their life for God
displaying the virtue of fortitude
courage beyond what most are capable of
Dante recounts seeing millions of Sparks
of light representing Souls that form
the shape of a Greek cross on the
planet's surface he Compares this to the
Milky Way on Mars Dante meets an
ancestor of his that took part in the
Second Crusade just like most of those
Dante meets in his poem his great great
grandfather reminisces about Florence in
the 12th century and expresses his
sorrow over the current state of
Florence Dante asks what his future
holds and is told that hardships will
fall upon him because he will be exiled
from Florence all is not lost though it
is Dante's mission to write and tell the
world about his journey what he has seen
in Hell purgatory and Paradise this
mission is of utmost importance
sphere number six is the planet Jupiter
the place of just rulers because of its
association with Jupiter the king of
Gods the souls here form to spell love
Justice ye that judge the Earth with
some of the other Souls forming the
shape of an Imperial Eagle the Imperial
Eagle speaks to Dante telling him
despite its composition of all the just
Kings Divine Justice is the single
concept that Dante must trust even when
it's workings are Beyond his
comprehension Justice can seem unfair
and flawed at times when in the hands of
false leaders however Divine Justice is
unwavering the Eagle's eyes are made up
of King David emperor Constantine
Hezekiah William II of Sicily and two
pagans Emperor trajan and the Trojan
hero rythius who were saved by God
himself Dante recalls seeing trajan in
purgatory on the Terrace of Pride
surrounded by his soldiers Dante
questions what happens to those born
before Christ and rifias is used to
explain rypheus was deemed so worthy of
Grace that God saved him and made him a
Christian a thousand years before anyone
else the main premise of this idea is
that salvation is the belief that Jesus
is the Messiah it makes no difference if
you were born before or after Christ
everyone is given a chance to ascend to
Heaven sphere number seven is the planet
Saturn home to those who are masters of
self-restraint and Temperance the souls
on Saturn climb up and down an enormous
Golden Ladder and find themselves very
close to God this fear mostly consists
of the discussion regarding practice
Services of devoted Christians with the
monk Peter Damien together they
discussed the sad state of the current
Church Saint Benedict discusses his
disappointment in his own monks who
nowadays seem more interested in
material value than spiritual existence
Beatrice persuades Dante to climb the
Golden Ladder himself and look down at
the earth a tiny insignificant Speck
below a lesson in perspective sphere 8
is the fixed stars of Faith Love and
Hope home to the church triumphant Dante
is immediately overwhelmed by the
presence of the Virgin Mary Saint Peter
steps forward to challenge and test
Dante regarding the nature of his faith
a test that Dante passes next is Saint
James who appears to test Dante on the
subject of Hope Dante again n is
successful and is taken to Saint John
his presence is so bright that Dante
loses his sight Saint John testante on
the subject of love using his experience
so far Dante's new look on love allows
him to pass the third and final test his
vision is restored and now he can see
even more than he could before before
leaving the sphere Saint Peter denounces
the modern Church
Dante looking down at the earth once
more is taken to the premium mobile
sphere number nine and the home of the
Angels this sphere is moved by God
himself and in turn causes all of the
surrounding spheres to also move Dante
sees a piercing and burning light
surrounded by Nine Circles of fire
unable to comprehend what's before him
Beatrice explains that these represent
the nine different ranks of angels that
orbit around the love of God the Angels
were created at the same time as the
universe and so they radiate God's love
throughout the various different spheres
Beatrice and Dante finally pass into the
imperian a region Beyond physical
existence the restraints of time and
space do not exist here the empyrean is
what many refer to as true Paradise in
order to understand and comprehend the
Wonders around him Dante must shrink
from a River of Lights when he sees
Beatrice she is even more beautiful than
before the souls here bathe in the light
and gather in the shape of a white rose
everything here is infinitely happy
something that Dante can now finally
begin to understand
Beatrice takes her rightful place with
the other souls and by Dante's side to
guide him now is Saint Bernard here the
souls have earned a different ranks and
must trust this judgment to be divine
Dante looks at the Virgin Mary shining
bright greater than everyone else around
her Bernard prays to Mary so that she
may give Dante the strength required to
gaze into the light of God this is the
one moment that Dante's entire Journey
has led to with the prayer complete he
finally looks into the light of God the
light is unlike anything he has
experienced before so powerful he
struggles to express the Wonders before
him there are three lights total three
large circles that represent the Trinity
the circles allow Dante to gaze upon the
human form of Christ he tries to
understand how these circles fit
together but all of a sudden Dante is
hit with a burst of love so powerful
that his memory disappears and the only
thing he remains conscious of is his own
free will finally Dante knows how it
feels to be in complete unit person and
harmony with God's will
but already my desire and my will were
being turned like a wheel all at one
speed by the love which moves the Sun
and other stars
I hope you've enjoyed Dante's Journey
Through Hell purgatory and Paradise it
is a goal of mine this year to cover
more epic pieces of literature both
classic and modern so stay tuned for
those
foreign
[Music]